welcome back to the game SWAT stayed
here at e3 2017 joining myself and two
more here today talk about Call of Duty
World War two is Michael Condrey who's a
co-founder of sledgehammer games Michael
thanks so much for joining us thank you
for having me how was your show going so
far oh it is amazing I mean three years
in development we get to share what
we've been working on with fans it's
been fantastic receptions and great we
couldn't be more excited right and one
of the interest things about you as a
studio is like you came in when Call of
Duty was really popular and you provided
this you know the third studio so you're
kind of the new kids on the Call of Duty
block but now you've been tasked with
kind of changing Call of Duty in a quite
a drastic way from what your husband for
the past four years how does it feel to
go from being the new kid on the block
to like redefining quality again it's
been an incredible journey and you're
right we turn eight sledgehammer games
turns eight this year yeah it's been
nearly a decade since college Aires been
in World War two so for us the chance to
take it back to its roots to take a
beloved franchise back to where it began
it's a real honor for sledgehammer games
and yeah we are the newest of the lead
Studios but we've done modern we did
advanced and now we're back to boots on
the ground right and why did you
obviously a lot of people are gonna
wonder what decide what was the deciding
factor in going back to world war ii I
mean it's a lot of people will say it's
the trend now but there must be
something more than everyone wants it or
everyone's doing it now to you guys that
made you decide we should go back to the
roots of it was a kind of an attempt to
refocus on what quality it was when it
started yeah you know we we really enjoy
the interaction with fans I mean it fans
are paramount to what we do and coming
out of modern warfare it was clear it
was all about innovation they wanted a
new way to play call of duty and that
was really the inspiration for advanced
warfare and we brought a lot of
innovation to advanced warfare but the
new movement said in the exo and all
those things and our relationship with
the fans continued and it was clear
there was an opportunity to then bring
it back to boots on the ground which is
strategic and fast-paced and grounded
but rooted in a cause that's really
remarkable and we hadn't touched in a
decade so it's really that engagement
with fans that has led us to to this
game so going back from so obviously
like in in modern Call of Duty's like
the the movement has been you know that
much
more you can reach that much higher
going back to as you say boots on the
ground how are you going to sort of make
that like the new standard for Call of
Duty I guess after reaching the sort of
mechanical Heights yeah well you know
fan reception here at e3 is being
fantastic and I think we've captured
what makes multiplayer great you know
it's grounded its strategic its
fast-paced it's got an arsenal of World
War 2 weapons and iconic locations so
for us it feels like what made call duty
great and you're seeing some stuff here
on screen from multiplayer where it's
really about that experience of you and
your squad in this gritty and intense
World War 2 conflict so it feels right
and for us we couldn't be more proud of
bringing this this year especially
coming off with the games we did in the
past yeah yeah you've obviously had
playtesting going on and that kind of
stuff from your experience has it have
you seen people kind of reach for
needing to retrain themselves a bit
because I mean I'm someone who plays you
know the modern quality is titanfall and
all these other like lawbreakers that
kind of stuff it's a very kinetic
momentum base you're doing way more like
it's almost like you're playing the
piano with a longer controller or
something so like the idea of thing
equality that kind of scripts all that
way all that way kind of makes me think
I might need to relearn some of the
simplicity's or like take it easier
again because you can be seen that
happen with play testing and yourself
like is there a learning curve to going
backwards to almost you know it's really
natural and it feels very strategic you
know the gameplay feels like Call of
Duty but what we love is its strategic
threat identification and lanes make
sense when it's rooted on the ground and
so we pick it up I don't know maybe it's
like getting on a bike again
yes feels really natural I guess it
helps that there's a lot of like classic
first-person shooter games that are
still very popular on the PC and and
stuff like simple games like for example
player non backgrounds it's mechanically
quite simple it doesn't have any of that
movement stuff people are really into
that the MA
that must be quite exciting for you guys
to be in that moment as well yeah you
know look we we couldn't have made this
game on the consoles ten years ago
there's a lot of innovation here this
the consoles are so powerful today so
we've got a ton of innovations we've
never seen before in World War two like
our new war mode and divisions and
headquarters all of these things that
are first but that feeling of that
grounded Call of Duty action that we've
all loved for more than a decade it
feels right right it must help you kind
of does it help you tell a more focused
story as well because obviously with the
previous games the kind of they're all
over the place they become like Michael
Bay style you know explosive you're
leaping around and doing crazy things
that and it's hard to keep track of a
story in characters in that kind of
scenario because you're just being wowed
by the spectacle of it all instead so
has this allows you to kind of tell a
more focus story on a more a story that
will resonate with people perhaps in a
way that you know classic quality is
dead and maybe in a way that for example
quality forded yeah each of the games
we've made in Call of Duty has had its
own creative challenge and opportunity
this one with the the canvas of world
war ii and the backdrop of the world's
deadliest conflict it's powerful it's a
powerful story it's a moment in human
history and inflection where really the
the planet was on the brink of tyranny
root and so you have to provide
entertainment the fans are going to have
fun with and we've done that but you
also have to be respectful of the cause
of the sacrifice of what really happened
at that time so that balance actually
has been something that the studio is
really embraced to honor and respect the
sacrifices of world war ii and you'll
have those big moments there'll be those
opportunities to really showcase some of
the most destructive battles in world
war ii but there's this intensely
personal moments world war ii that i
think will will shine in it in their own
way too we imagine these personal
moments and it's gonna be like you and
your squad how have you so I mean a lot
of the times if you can play any type of
game and if you have like an AI
companion you might not necessarily be
that inclined to you know form a
relationship with them or they might be
a hindrance I mean games like by cooking
for example you had Elizabeth as your
air companion but she
that was useful and like she would give
you things hmm are you kind of following
that to kind of work a relationship with
there with your squad or is it more like
there's going to be a real impactful
personal story there - yeah we really
want you to connect with this squad so
you follow the squad out of the 1st
Infantry Division now the 1st Infantry
Division was 15,000 troops and you're
following a small group with red Daniels
as the leader of that group an original
story coming out sledgehammer games for
World War 2 based on real world events
but we really want you to feel the
struggle you know the success the loss
along the way you'll meet a global and
diverse cast you'll connect with
Rousseau who's a strong female leader
the French Resistance but our hope is
that that squad Daniels and others
really you connect with and the
narrative team spent a lot of time
really trying to bring that to life
right how do you guys obviously you
mentioned it briefly there but it's kind
of like Rey piqued my interest like
balancing the idea of creating a game
for entertainment with also exploring
the war and because there are obviously
there's a big discussion about all the
different atrocities that happened
during that war and how games
traditionally have tried to skirt around
them but you've said in the past aids
you're going to try and go to some dark
places and you need to do that in order
to be respectful of the war itself and
the sacrifices that were made so can you
talk a bit about how you kind of
approach that from from an entertainment
perspective as well as a storytelling
perspective yeah I'm glad you asked I
mean that's a really complex question
trying to deliver on the authenticity of
the war and you're right I mean upwards
of a hundred million people perished in
this war worst atrocities in human
history so there's the authenticity of
the war that we want to deliver but we
also have to be very respectful of the
people who lost their lives and
sacrificed and we struggle on that from
everything around Nazi iconography in
the game including the swastika yeah and
so with our military historian and a lot
of focus on the studio we are trying to
find that balance and you'll see the
swastika in
parts of the narrative parts of the
campaign not in multiplayer and zombies
because that's a global community and
there's regional laws that we have to
respect but I tell you we went literally
to the the footsteps we sat in Normandy
we went to Germany and France we saw
these battle locations stood in the
foxholes that they're still here today
and when you when you invest in that
level of research it sort of in parts of
profound respect for what happened so it
is entertainment and it's also a telling
story of the world's grittiest war but
it must also be a tremendous amount of
pressure to sort of respect
the events of what happened and the
memories of people who died absolutely
and you know when we started it was for
us about telling the story so it could
never happen again
run so this atrocity in this you know
world on the brink of tyranny moment we
can't let that happen again
and it's in some ways faded from human
consciousness writers the war that's 80
years ago but as we do of deeper and we
talk to the veterans and we research we
realize that most of the people that
fought that battle they're not here
today yeah so now here to tell them
stories themselves and so I think
respect and honor is really what
probably the two words that come most in
mind and how we've treated this this
creative and the similar vein how did
you approach introduced not interested
about having a fan-favorite mold like
zombies because you've got this like I
know why you did it of course and I'm
I'm a fan of that mode so like but it's
got a bit had been a discussion way like
we're trying to be faithful to this
world war thing how do we introduce
something that we know everyone wants
and will enjoy but we don't want to
create this perception where we're
taking the rest of it lightly by
introducing this fun mode that's all
about zombies and so how did you
approach that yeah you know each of the
modes sort of has their own creative
Drive in priorities and campaign is
really about delivering that
authenticity in that deeply personal
story multiplayer is very social and
competitive and there are some liberties
there and and you're right nazi zombies
return of nazi zombies we can't sit here
and say that there's authenticity to
that and nor do fans really want that
right like this is a creative outlet
now it's rooted on where the franchise
began you know zombies and Call of Duty
started in Nazi zombies so that's an
honor for us and we get to put a sledge
hammer game stamp on that you know our
our background with dead space yeah yeah
it'll be an adrenaline-filled take on it
it's rooted in some research we found
about some of the beliefs that that
Germans had about Nazi occult origins
yeah we have done we intimate research
there you go yeah we think it's going to
be really fun for fans to have that
outlet but you're right the authenticity
doesn't quite apply to Nazis as to the
campaign cool one of the other things
you mentioned was war mode which is
something that's really interesting me
can you tell people about what that is
and kind of what your idea behind was
that was why you decided to introduce
something like that war modes brand-new
game mode in multiplayer this year first
to Call of Duty and you know three years
ago we were talking about this idea of
how you really get the the feeling of
big war of squad based warfare which
really was what world war 2 was about
it's not the Super Soldier it's not the
lone wolf experience it was about group
of common men and women coming together
to fight and so we wanted to capture
that and war mode is our answer to that
sort of creative challenge it's access
versus Allied it's a narrative driven
asymmetrical experience where you're
really colliding on these battle fronts
that happened and you saw some of that
in the trailer that we released this
week where you know the first objective
is to take the manor or defend the manor
or take the bridge esque with the tank
protect the ammo dumps and so this gives
us that opportunity to bring that
conflict to life in a way that really
feels new and unique to call it a world
war 2 and obviously it has a narrative
element to it that you want players to
focus more on the story you're telling
or is it about the micro stories that
happen within the gauge minh trail ii
kind of selling the narrative part of
that mode yeah it's more about grounding
the conflict in world war ii and i think
we're seeing a little bit well this is
multiplayer at one point to Hawking in
deathmatch but you'll see that really
this set up is trying to make that feel
like a true conflict in world war
and these moments where access and
allied came together to fight for these
strategic positions was really what the
war was about and so you'll see in our
war mode that sort of narrative micro
story if you will grounding it in a way
that's really powerful right yeah let's
talk about your you have a new sort of
headquarters like a social space you
tell us a little bit about that yeah
absolutely
headquarters for call of duty we think
this is the biggest innovation in
multiplayer this year and it's a true
first for the franchise for us you know
if you if you go back six years which is
a long time in game development at the
beginning of advanced warfare you were
really just a gamertag and a rank and
the other player and we saw an
opportunity to bring your character to
life really have you invest in that that
character avatar and we delivered that
in the virtual lobby gave you a chance
to sort of show off in a small setting
and this is the evolution of that this
is taking you into a true space where
your character your investment your
division advancements and customizations
now have a place to live 48 players come
together in this living world where you
can compete new ways like our 1v1 or
shoot offs in the in the virtual firing
range that now becomes a living firing
range you can be rewarded be social
peacock and show off in ways that we
know the community loves to do so
there'll be more about to see on
headquarters later at the beta but this
is a big one for us yeah that seems
really interesting because one of the
issues I had was like that first the
loop of it you know leveling up and
unlocking things it were I really loved
it in the first few like mana warfare
and warfare 2 and the fuel rail games
but now I feel like I'm just kind of
running endlessly on a grind so that
seems like an interesting way of getting
people to re-engage with that kind of
loop again so it sounds encouraging it
really is and you know we talked a lot
about these moments that are super
important in your multiplayer
progression like prestiging and if you
think about it in the past prestiging is
there was very little fanfare you did it
you know this was a moment in your
progression that really is like the
pinnacle of your accomplishment and you
you hit a button at home by yourself and
you get a little cell
to everything you know dance you've done
it right now in headquarters you get to
go to what we're in development terms
calling prestige ease overwatch where
you go up on the cliff above the whole
headquarters and you prestige in front
of the whole community and they get to
celebrate with you right and that's how
it should be this is a moment in your
progression that's important and now we
give you a space to do that with your
friends and other members of the
community that's cool one of the things
I was really interested in is where
you're getting your influences and what
you're looking to obviously you have a
lot of research done and the real world
is your primary influence and your
source but you know obviously it's hard
not to make connections to other types
of media stuff like Band of Brothers
Saving Private Ryan what are you looking
to to kind of thematically and
aesthetically kind of sell your game and
present it to people
you're right research really was at the
core of it and everything from going to
museums in New Orleans of remarkable
World War two museum there or the museum
in Luxembourg which is phenomenal or
these trips that we went on with the
military historian boots on the ground
actually there that really is the
essence of it and you have to do that to
really understand the conflict from on
the ground level no pun intended but
there are also inspirations clearly from
other points of media like Saving
Private Ryan right
now the crazy thing about simply Ryan is
it's 20 years old I know it doesn't seem
like that's a reaction to everybody I
can make it today and it would be holds
up very well it's maybe the most iconic
depiction of World War two in film so
for us yes films like Saving Private
Ryan clearly modern films like I don't
know I guess Black Hawk Down you know
how to take on what war meant in a
different era
but for us giving the chance to give a
new generation maybe generations never
seen Saving Private Ryan or even Band of
Brothers which was ten years ago or
played Call of Duty that hasn't been
there in nearly a decade this might be
their first exposure so we wanted to
capture that in our own way there you go
be as bold as to say you want this to be
the Saving Private Ryan of the current
gaming generation for absolutely no
absolutely I mean for people who are
coming back like you and me who played
call of duty from the beginning right
you want this to feel really powerful
and new
for people who are playing it for the
first time we hope that that we hope
that that's an experience that they will
look to now as their pop culture sort of
iconic experience in world war two
awesome
it's an incredible amount of pressure
there as well though you're sort of
providing a cultural and historical
touch point for a lot of people yeah
you're right and I'm so thankful for the
the team of sledgehammer games everybody
at Activision because you know that
pressure it you can feel it and and
moments like this at e3 to celebrate
with fans that's a huge honour for us
because it kind of reinvigorates that
that drive but you're right this is a
beloved franchise and in many ways I
think about I don't know Abrams having a
chance to sort of put his stamp on Star
Wars beloved franchise that that is
existed for a very very long time in pop
culture maybe that might be a bridge too
far I don't know but like that that
pressure that opportunity that
experience for our studio is really
front of them we take to heart okay
stepping back a bit going back to the
mechanical level something I just
remembered you talked about kind of
going back to roots and that means doing
things like removing crutches or
gameplay facets of Call of Duty that
people are well familiar with and the
second nature stuff like unlimited
sprint recovering health so can you talk
about the process of reaching the
decision to do that because that's a big
thing it's not just a Call of Duty thing
that's a fundamental design principle of
the genre now so how do you how do you
go about making the decision to roll
that back and as there were any
discussions that were there any
discussions where you're like we can't
do this it's too fundamental to what
games of first-person shooters are now a
great thing about having three year
development cycles with Activision is
you have the time to really be ambitious
and that gives us time to be more
innovative and more thoughtful in our
approach and multiplayer specifically we
want to take that time to really look at
every part of the multiplayer experience
including progression and create a class
which we've now sort of replaced with
divisions a new but refined approach to
your soldier career in campaign with the
removal of auto-generating health system
and having that replaced with health
packs yeah that's a big step yeah now we
feel like it's absolutely the right
decision for World War two there's a
different conflict you weren't a tier 1
super soldier of the future who had all
the tech and information you needed at
your hands and it feels right for us
those conversations we've had from day
one and frankly we're still having to
make sure that the things that make
already great we preserve but the
experience feels right for the era I
guess I guess a kind of change like
having to rely on your friends and your
squad mates to help you through about
all this kind of reinforces the
narrative that you're trying to deliver
as well right absolutely and you asked
about inspiration and I'll be honest I
love bandar brothers and a lot of those
episodes were really talking about how
these impactful characters like the
medic really brought that squad together
and kept them alive and we want to
capture that in our experience as well
okay cool
one of the things I was interested in is
how have you seen the has the pacing of
multiplayer change because current
modern-day ecology is like it's very
you're dying quickly and respawning and
have you seen people kind of be a little
more cautious in the way they approach
my player now because we live in you
know the current state of ecology is
like you run straight in good chancer if
you see someone you can backflip out of
the way or slide out of the way or leap
across a building or something like that
all right yeah exactly now you have a
quality where that's impossible you
can't do these phases and have you seen
people kind of like has the pace of
multiplayer slowed down somewhat you
know it's a great question
the fast sort of gun on gun action
that's really grounded in Call of Duty
fans want that and we want to deliver it
but with these iconic weapons and these
real signature weapons from world war ii
the engagements are very different right
whether you're running a trench gun
shoddy and a small map like point to
hawk which you saw or you're a sniper
there is a different sort of approach to
it now it's fast and it's frenetic and
it and it delivers on everything we love
about Call of Duty multiplayer and we've
built maps that's specifically tailored
to different playstyles so you you get a
more of a breadth of play style and
divisions leads in that tattoo so I
guess the short answer is it
captures that that grounded fast-action
multiplayer experience but there is new
strategy that really is important to how
you play right how does that I don't
know if you discussed your ambitions for
it but how does that fit into kind of
like the professional competitive scene
because obviously even even the kind of
thematic and the way the professional
quality league is sold is about fast
it's almost like American football style
like really who are and this kind of
like high energy kind of kind of
presentation to all and that kind of
fits with the frenetic nature of current
Call of Duty and have you thought about
how your kind of slower paced more boots
on the ground and realistic Call of Duty
impacts that and do you think that the
scene will kind of take to that they're
used to doing a lot and showing off that
they're the best at leaping around and
that kind of stuff so this might be kind
of a very different change you expect it
to kind of shift the way eSports happens
around quality yeah we have a lot of
eSports announcements coming later this
this summer as you know from our studio
and Activision there's a big investment
in eSports and we love engaging with the
players early and I can tell you they
are going to love this experience and
really a lot of it is because the
strategy of being on the ground again
and mastering the maps and really
focusing on your ability with your
arsenal of weapons is what they want and
I think they're going to go bananas for
this one we're already seeing it at the
event there's been a lot of influence
we've come in and played with us and
give us great feedback I think fans are
gonna be able to give us feedback at the
beta that's coming later this summer too
so I think about time we get to the
sports season it's gonna feel great okay
cool um and final question I think what
do you want this what do you want
ecology to World War two to be
remembered for mm-hmm wow that's a
powerful question one to end on well I
think you know sledgehammer games you
know we talked about this commitment to
excellence into quality and I hope if
players are campaign players or zombie
players or multiplayer
players or maybe they play all of it
they'll appreciate the commitment from
the studio to deliver quality for the
experience and bigger than that I hope
that people really feel the respect and
honor that we
I've brought to try and you know frankly
bring world war two to consciousness in
a respectful wave okay cool
Oh Michael thank you so much for joining
us what an absolute pleasure can't wait
to play for more from this year's e3
make sure you don't go anywhere we'll be
talking about mataf all in just a few
short minutes we'll see you then